I want to welcome you all on behalf of
the lemelson-mit program and the
author's lecture series of MIT and the
MIT press I want to welcome you to this
launching of our book the inventing
modern America from microwave to mouse I
the book by the way was conceived by the
staff of the lemelson-mit program for
for several years ago well before I
became associated with it my name is
Merton Fleming's by the way on the
faculty of MIT by the staff who was
conceived by the staff of the program
and Lester Thurow
and finally brought to fruition recently
with the support of the Lemelson
Foundation and with the authorship of
David Brown who is here David thank you
very much I might mention a few other
distinguished people here apart from the
panel members there are several others
associated with the with the book which
brings us all together here dr. Stan of
schinsky president and CEO of energy
systems and mrs. Ethel gross here the
wife of Al gross
dr. Al gross
mrs. grose reminded me today told me
today that it was just a year ago today
that her husband was taken ill and in
the last few months of his life spent a
great deal of time continuing to think
inventive thoughts and I think
continuing to tell people about the
important prize he he won and I'm sure
it was more than more than more than one
the lemelson-mit program is one express
thanks to that also not only for the
support of the book in part but also for
the support of our program at MIT of our
work and raising published public
consciousness of invention of rewarding
inventors and now of our new program in
focusing on promoting encouraging high
school students to invent and in
invention I'm happy to now introduce one
of the sons of Jerry Levinson and a
member of the board of the foundation of
the the Lemelson foundation Rob Lemelson
who will say just a word or two thank
you
thanks Mert I'm bi on behalf of the
Lemelson foundation I'd like to start
off by giving a deep note of gratitude
appreciation for this project particular
to Lester Thurow and Mert Flemming the
new director Chris and Finn but
particularly anne-marie Amparo who was
the director and shepherded the program
really from its inception I just want to
mention a few things about the Lemelson
foundation we were started by my dad in
the early 90s with the sole purpose of
promoting invention and innovation in
America and to that end we have a
National Center for the study of
invention and innovation at the
Smithsonian and I invite you all to go
and and visit there we have the
lemelson-mit program with our student
prize $30,000 student prize and our half
million dollar annual prize in our
lifetime achievement award we have
national collegiate inventors and
innovators Alliance that we give
numerous small grants to college
inventors who otherwise wouldn't have
the seed capital or ability to bring
their inventions to market and a number
of other programs our new orientation
for the foundation or new direction is
bringing invention and innovation to
address basic human needs in the
developing world and we're just getting
that off the ground right now I'm so
delighted to be here but this book
really it's it celebrates human
imagination an imagination can cut both
ways but it's possible to an imagine a
world without a world where our soldiers
would be going to battle without the
protection of Kevlar vests invented by
stephanie kwok or the walkie-talkie
invented by al gross it's it's possible
to imagine a world where millions
wouldn't have their disease diagnosed
with an MRI invented by raid to mate in
or would have died without the benefit
of a cardiac pacemaker by Wilson
Greatbatch
or the balloon angioplasty by Thomas
Fogarty where my favorite computer the
Macintosh does not exist by Steve
Wozniak and and powered by my favorite
input device the mouse by Douglas
Engelbart so that's the negative side
now imagine a world where new polymers
allow doctors to deliver
chemotherapy more effectively with fewer
side-effects and allow doctors to grow
new bones or even internal organs by Rob
Langer where computers can write poetry
stories paint or perhaps one day even
debate and probably win debates of
whether they're conscious beings
conceptualized by Ray Kurzweil or in the
future nanotechnology devices that can
construct new materials machines and
medications on a molecule by molecule
basis by Brian Hubert all of these
inventors and their achievements have
been honored through the awarding of the
lemelson-mit prize either as grad
students in the case of Brian or the
inventor of the year in case of Bob
Langer and Ray Kurzweil or our lifetime
achievement award winner Douglas
Engelbart all of whom are here today and
will address you so I'm really delighted
to be here and I'll turn it back to Mary
well it wasn't easy but Rob and I have
been our lips and kept our comments
almost as short as we plan to and my
happy job now is to turn the rest of the
evening over to our host for the evening
Chris Lydon founder and former host of
Boston Public Radio's the connection
thank you it's a great pleasure to be
here and an extraordinary panel we have
it seemed to me the beauty of this book
or one of the many beauties of it is
that it's so personal it's so
biographical as opposed to technical
much less ideological and I thought we
would try to keep the evening in that
spirit these are real people men of
imagination and a certain poetry who
have done these wonders and unlike
unlike the deal with them in that
fashion rather than introduce them all
formally I'd like them to introduce
themselves but with a specific little
trick question on which they've all been
forewarned I'd like each of them
starting with Doug Engelbart to speak of
their own kind of God as an inventor I
mean who in in the world of inventors
really has sort of Joe DiMaggio kind of
standing for them in terms of
achievement but in terms of a kind of
emotional identity in example who's your
Joe DiMaggio Doug Engelbart I'm slowly
make up my mind
so sometimes it's edison and sometimes
it's galileo sometimes it's Ben Franklin
and sometimes it's Aristotle so sorry
say that those are for heavy hitters
Edison Aristotle starting with eros and
Edison anyways Aristotle but you had
Galileo and Ben Franco that's
fascinating okay that'll do
Leonardo is yet to be claimed Brian it's
your turn
well I wondered frankly I was gonna get
to this later how did this book leave
out Edwin land but that's another matter
I don't mean to lead the witness go
ahead it's your turn Brian well if I may
be so bold as to point out actually a
fine gentleman actually sitting in the
audience
Standish rimsky who has had a very long
career I'm still reading books that that
deal with his work on the study and
development of amorphous thin film
materials that date back to nineteen
nineteen fifty-five 1960s
development of memory films and then
switching over later on in in life to CD
development so now these thin films are
actually being used for mass storage and
CD recording and then of course solar
cells as well I'd like to point out
another person which i think maybe
people don't necessarily consider an
inventor outright and that is a Frank
Lloyd Wright an architect he was before
the time of Frank Lloyd Wright many
buildings and architecture consisted of
closed rooms that were separated one to
another with a central hallway and and
today we live in buildings and homes
that have this kind of a free-flowing
architecture to them and in reality you
know maybe it's not patentable but
certainly makes a big influence on our
lives thank you breaker as well well I
mentioned to people who had some
influence on me none becoming an
inventor because I think I decided that
before I had heard of either of these
people but one is Edison who have
learned something about later in life
and have tried to emulate some of
the approaches and methods he used he
did have a specific discipline about
inventing and saw him selves
specifically as an invention to find
himself that way and was one of the
first to do that and he had a whole
methodology which involved being a
student of technology trends and trying
to anticipate where technology was going
the idea being that your invention has
to make sense when you're finished with
the project not when you start and the
world will be a different place by the
time you get the project done and so
that's led me to be a student of
technology trends and that kind of took
on a life of its own so I began to
anticipate trends going out some decades
which enabled me as a writer to invent
with the technology capabilities and
computational resources of future times
and Edison did that as well and he kept
very detailed logs of where technology
was going and what might be possible
today but what which inventions you
might have to wait until certain other
materials were available he had a whole
group process where he would actually a
large part of being an inventor as being
a teacher and a salesperson we try to
inspire other people not only your
investors but most particularly the
other engineers and scientists that
you're working with and he had a whole
group process a whole laboratory devoted
to invention so I I find his approach to
be to be inspiring another person who's
not really seen as inventor but Marvin
Minsky actually was a mentor of mine
going back quite early when I was in
high school I corresponded with him and
I came up here to Cambridge and met with
him and he had this vision of ultimately
making computers as intelligent as
people and that fact that really turned
me on it brought me here at MIT and I've
kept up that dialogue with Marvin for
almost 40 years now
thank you Robert later well for me it's
also a personal experience and the man I
would give is dr. Judah Folkman who is a
professor at Harvard Medical School
he was my when I after I graduated from
MIT he was the person I did my
postdoctoral work with and what he has
done as some people may have followed
his career is a sort of invent a family
of drugs that can stop how blood vessels
grow which is I think one of our great
hopes today for possibly preventing
cancer but in addition to that he's done
a lot of other interesting things over a
wide area right spectrum even developed
doing some of the early work that led to
the noir plant as well as a number of
other things but to me it was not just
the specific inventions but more the
attitude and more the way he looked at
things like he wasn't afraid to see the
future wasn't afraid to in fact was very
interested in combining different
disciplines and he believed I think that
anything was possible and never gave up
in the face of just enormous amounts of
criticism I think these kinds of
elements were wonderful for me as a
young scientist to say and have really
inspired me through throughout my life
yes I think I'm back I think of a lot of
people that were really more like
scientists you know Galileo and Newton
and Richard Fineman and all that and I
don't really think of them in the in
thinner category and if I had a hero in
life I'd probably link back well God
helped make me the way I am and probably
Bob Dylan so I go back you know I have
these all these things in me like I'm
sure all of us did that we're like
inventors you know very early in agent
you know eight years old and on and it
was really had to be my father who was
an engineer who I wanted to be like and
I told him in sixth grade I want to be
an engineer like you and maybe second to
that a teacher because they're important
too and my father's always there helped
me to teach me things to answer
questions to inspire me to go a little
further with my electronics work I also
had books that inspire you when you're
young you read a book and for some
reason it grabs you and kind of takes
you in that direction life and there
might have been some technical TV shows
on but for me it was books and I would
always buy the Tom Swift junior books
about this guy who was young with his
friend and he was an engineer and he
owned a company with his father and they
just whenever there was a pro
in the world he'd go into the lab for
two weeks or two days and two days and
nights and designed a solution to entrap
the aliens to fly to win a spaceship
race to to have a submarine to solve
some problem and Swift that was my early
hero another good example of the author
was I read a book and it was just a
bunch of people that had a little radial
Club that sent signals to each other and
a guy got kidnapped and he outsmarted
the kidnappers by wiring their TV to
send some signals to his friends and
right after reading that book in fifth
grade I went to school and said I'm
gonna get a ham radio license because it
said anybody if any age can get one and
it was just that neat little sentence at
the end of the book that real inspired
me so I had to ham license by sixth
grade and pretty much from then on I had
an inventor's life he could build things
and you know you never really have to
worry about having some sort of job so
[Applause]
some of you touched on it already you're
talking about Judah Bachmann's kind of
courage about the future and a kind of
can-do thing but in stirrup I'd like to
ask anybody and plunge in is there an
x-factor that separates you know a very
good engineer from being an inventor or
a very good biologist from being what
what is the difference between just a
first-class professional and then and
and the kind of folk that invented
modern America well I think there's
probably a lot of answers to that I'm
sure everybody you know obviously
there's things like creativity and
brilliant but I guess I go back to also
thinking about you know a lot of time
I'll just give one element I think that
everybody can maybe give different ones
I'm sure there's a lot I think one thing
is andreas said this in different ways
about learning how to deal with failure
you know the way I look at it is you
know most of the time when you do stuff
when you try to invent when you try to
do science you things won't work and so
it's you know and so you can deal with
that a lot of different ways but I think
a lot of times people that are most
successful are the ones that know how to
deal with failure the best that just
know you know aren't going to let that
get the
to them they'll just say okay I'm gonna
get it the next time and eventually you
do you know there's enormous amounts of
perseverance no matter what anybody says
no matter how hard something seems yeah
well Edison tried out several hundred
filaments before he got one that worked
and usually I mean the only person who
can declare failure is is yourself when
you finally give up and decide that you
haven't been able to get something at
work but if you view failure it's just
success to further than then you don't
have to experience failure another
aspect of the difference between a
scientist and inventor and it's not
really a value judgment the scientists
values knowledge knowledge does end up
being useful in the end but an inventor
really speaking for myself takes great
pleasure in seeing what I call the the
leap from dry formulas on a blackboard
to actual impact in people's lives so
actually seeing people use your
inventions and have a benefit and seeing
it actually make a difference in the
world in the real world that's what
turns in an inventor on and usually an
inventor is applying some scientific
knowledge but that that's that's the
sort of joy in inventing I bring in the
strange word of a dreamer that that's
what's driven me all the time and you
sort of have dreams they're actually not
have to be practical at all to be a
dream that you think gee that would be
really neat and so that's what's driven
me all through the years is the dream
about how much people can collectively
improve their ability to do complex
urgent sort of solutions and I remember
how I bothered I was when at one time
some guy who was in head of an ARPA
division was quoted as saying oh angle
Bart he's just a dreamer and thought it
made me mad the word just
it's that's serious hard work would you
be more particular about you know
particular dreams you said you know that
would be neat I mean and broaden it past
the mouse perhaps
oh the mouse was just a little thing
like a windshield wiper on a new brand
of vehicles and no though the whole
thing started out over fifty years ago
and and realizing that the world is
really getting more and more complex all
the time and they're urging big problems
that have to be dealt with collectively
and urgency difficulties going up like
this and our collective ability is
inching if anything and so it'd be very
very important to the world that that we
really learn how to boost our collective
IQ if we want to call it so I dream
about it that's boy there really are
opportunities to do that and you can go
can I just say parent I like the
Dreaming idea and it reminds me of a
wonderful disturbing story that
everybody should read called the dream
of a ridiculous man and it's about a guy
who is determined to kill himself on a
particular night and he he has the
revolver there and he but he falls into
a dream of sort of redeemed humanity and
an alternative earth and he spends the
rest of his life preaching about it and
he says people come up to me and say
that's just that's just a dream you had
and he said yeah but your reality maybe
want to kill myself and it's the dream
that told me the truth something related
to dreams this is magic and I was
actually one of the questions that I was
prepared to answer although I like this
format of just dialogue and better was
how did you get interested in inventing
and I was like thinking about that I got
it interested in inventing before I was
influenced by Edison or I've read any
books or because I got I'm not actually
sure entirely how I got interested in it
but I did have an interest very early in
life in magic magic tricks
if you think about what magic is if you
put certain materials and procedures in
just the right sequence it creates a
magical effect but ultimately ends up
being fairly superficial because if you
reveal some of the secrets behind the
magic it wrecks the magic but inventions
and technology and creating technology
is a form of magic particularly if you
master the art of the demo you give a
demo of here it's kind of like a magic
show that's supposed to have the same
impact but revealing the methods behind
technology does not wreck its effect and
ultimately the more profound
technologies have a real impact lasting
impact on the world so there's a magic
to it as a magic to any creation them
you put sound in the right sequence it
creates music so let me step back to the
x-factor I think that the difference
between an inventor and maybe this is
just like an imagination that we have
the way we perceive it inventor and a
real top scientist or engineer is that
the inventor still has like the child in
him and still has just a lot of humor
and fun is doing things for his own
purposes and reasons and not necessarily
for money in a business and I also think
that inventors kind of have this ability
to either forget that they know
something in order to design it better
or they don't know to begin with but
they are very smart about taking
components things are built out of and
putting them together in a new way than
that other people haven't considered
since components have changed our trips
have changed in a while and can kind of
come up with a good solution when it's
needed in effect teach themselves as
science rather than having been taught
it or learned it and just do it the way
it's always been done
and I also think that good that
inventors tend to seek very high levels
of quality in their work things that
other human beings wouldn't do either
because it's new or better and fewer
pieces than anyone else would do and
maybe they're competing with themselves
instead of competing with other people
or just trying to you know I think
they'd like to sit down and invent
something out of their head and make
changes as they go and keep modifying it
and not have the structure of defining
exactly what they're going to do on a
piece of paper and then doing exactly
that
can't vary from it and do anything
different and I also agree with the
comment that it should be practical I
also think that inventors tend to have a
broad range of interests as well and I
think you will find that all of the
gentlemen here have very inventions that
cover things from you know biology to
nanotechnology to computer chips and
Mouse's and so on but also inventors
feel at home in environments that you
wouldn't necessarily think they would be
so me myself as a mechanical engineer by
training might feel actually quite at
home dealing with a problem that might
other people might think might not have
anything to do with a mechanical
engineering solution being able address
problems in biology or this kind of
thing and Brian that touches on
multidisciplinary inventors tend to sit
down and design something and do the
drafting themselves and then put
together the breadboard themselves and
test it and modify it and rebuild it and
layout the PC board they tend to do a
lot of different tasks instead of just
one small part of it see go ahead in
terms of multiple tasks that I think
it's worth noting that I mean it's a
myth of an inventor who disappears into
his or her basement and emerges years
later from emergencies later with a
breakthrough and actually it's a group
of inventors of disappear into their
basement because inventing is very much
a group process or a few inventions
certainly in today's world that that are
done by a single person
they tend to be multidisciplinary so
you've got to gather people from
different disciplines who don't share
the same terminology so part of being an
inventor is being is having leadership
qualities I mentioned salesmanship
before I think that's very important you
have to have a vision and really believe
in it with such passion that it makes it
real and everybody just believes in it
and makes it happen regardless of
whether venture capital is up or down
and and can gather people to go through
the difficulty intellectual emotional
otherwise to to bring something to
fruition and then get a group to work
effectively together generally of
approach I use is to get everybody to
throw away their terminology and we
invent a new terminology
certainly helps in intellectual property
protection because of anybody over his
or conversations they have no idea what
we're talking about and then I'll try to
assign and say a signal processing
problem to the linguists or vice versa
to try to get some creative new ways of
approaching problems Steve you mentioned
mm-hmm
doing it for the money and not doing it
for the money and I wasn't sure we'd
ever get into the money question but I
I'm just I have two general questions
one is the world organized in such a way
from your standpoint to to give
inventors the right reward for their
genius for their contribution for their
work and secondly does the commercial
organization of the world bend the ideal
process of invention in other words
looking at this country I mean we will
probably invent a cure for baldness
before we invent a cure for malaria in
the third world and you wonder is that
is that right and is it something that
inventors worry about but go back to the
first question you know own own work
ownership your own work well first of
all yeah the I thought it was about our
rewards money or not money what's the
first part yeah so the inventor of this
person I think of is rewarded
intrinsically in their own brain knowing
what they're doing is valuable knowing
that it's good knowing that it's
something they wanted to do just like
solving a crossword puzzle and it's not
extrinsic where people can see where in
some fancy clothes or you live in a nice
house or you have a big salary or a big
title in a company or you know you own a
company it's it's not all this extrinsic
rewards you get a grade for something
and that's really motivating and I don't
think the inventor really needs the
money and it's doing it for the money
not the pure inventor anyway I think
maybe that comes later and you know
eventually you get why you wind up with
where well the the number one goal of
any company has to be to make money if
you have a good invention it gets being
sold and so the money kind of determines
what the company will pursue and its
proper but what happens is if a company
you know the way companies work in our
world is they become monopolies they get
control of some territory and then they
keep fighting they're putting up
the blocks to hold their territory
rather than pursuing newer better
technologies that will help people more
so that's that's more where where the
danger is rather than companies somehow
are just evil and they want to pursue
what's gonna make money instead of
what's not know even things that make
money they aren't going to pursue the
best ones they're going to pursue
whatever will hold their territory the
best I'd like to add some things to that
that in people have been telling me for
years that the marketplace is going to
take care of how you get organizations
to be more effective collectively and I
just point out two things like saying oh
there's an interesting collective
problem called the environment and it
certainly seemed like the marketplace is
taking care of it in the negative way
and there really are they're there
things that the marketplace isn't going
to take care of and somebody with
innovation etc has to start activity
that that it will mean what if some
inventor could figure out a way to leave
the next generation a better environment
then we came in sure I mean you can
invent all kinds of things I have a
response to both but was said I think
the rewards are intrinsic but you need
money as money to invent or is like clay
to a sculpture I mean it's an S it's
it's the necessary ingredient
particularly with the complex projects
we have today in terms of the
environment I think a key issue is sort
of the intertwined promise and peril of
technology technology solves a lot of
problems but it's its power that
empowers both our creative and
destructive sides and technology can be
harnessed for destructive ends as well
and I do think we need to apply more of
our creative powers to ameliorating some
of the vulnerabilities we have in some
of the destructive sides of technology
which have emerged well there's several
different aspects I mean technology is
power and I think spirit of this panel
is very much is the
book is the extent to which technology
has empowered our lives and I think
that's true if you go back several
hundred years compare our lives today to
then I mean most of this audience
wouldn't even be here because the
average life expectancy was 35 years and
most human life was poverty failed
disease prone labor intensive short
cetera so we have liberated ourselves to
a great extent through technology but
technology also empowers our destructive
sighs I mean the 20th century had two
great world wars a hundred million
people died certainly amplified and made
feasible by technology in September 11th
we saw technology commandeered
technology of airplanes and skyscrapers
not the most modern technology but still
technology used for destructive purposes
and there has been great concern that
has emerged over the potential for
technologies that are emerging in the
21st century which were vastly more
powerful than the very powerful 20th
century technologies to be used for
destructive purposes I mean the same
knowledge that that will I believe cure
cancer and overcome many diseases can
also be used by terrorists to create a
bioengineered pathogen and some people
have said well let's let's let's do the
good technologies and avoid the
dangerous ones unfortunately it's the
same knowledge the same technology and I
think the only answer really is I don't
I think we need to continue technology
development because there's a lot of
suffering to be overcome and there's a
lot of benefit to be gained and a lot of
creative expression to be harnessed and
I think we need to put a higher priority
on addressing the vulnerabilities that
some of these new technologies expose
and they're very specific projects that
need to be undertaken to do them you
keep sending me to ask you like what
what well I mean in the wake of
September 11th we've we can list a
hundred different ways in which society
is vulnerable today and that's that
itself is a dilemma because the press
talks about this and if
on the one hand we need that kind of
discussion in order to in a democratic
society to gather the will to do
something about these vulnerabilities on
the other hand if I were terrorists I
would you know listen to NPR and read
the New York Times and get a lot of
great ideas on each one of these
vulnerabilities are the things we can do
and it's a long discussion to talk about
each of them but even more importantly
some of the new things I mean I
mentioned the downsides of biotechnology
but there's specific projects for
example antiviral drugs that could
protect against a bio engineered virus
there's some very creative ideas that
are emerging but they we need to put a
higher priority on addressing the
defensive needs of defensive reaction to
some of these technology well I'd like
to point out that you know there's no
end of big problems and somehow getting
our society oriented about how to deal
how to focus on them which ones are
important is a collective issue that
just is falling behind and the United
Nations University put together a
project about six seven years ago and
they'd publish annually something called
the state of the future and they were
oriented about at saying at the turn of
the millennium what are going to be the
major challenges to mankind and so what
they published last year then was
there's sort of final one with fifth
listed 15 things that were large complex
issues that basically aren't being
centrally addressed by any part of our
world yet but which any any of those
could bring us down and so it's like
saying okay invention and the
marketplace does a certain amount of
stuff for us but who's who's getting out
there and being innovative in political
social other kind of organizational ways
that we start addressing these things in
some coherent way yeah but I think I
might be a little bit off topic rats
going back to the inventors need money
well it sort of seems like that but boy
I wouldn't tell that to anyone because
it's like saying there's no Santa Claus
you know I would say there's a lot of
people that went and they worked in the
basement alone
this incredible thing and their only
purpose was to build something neat for
their own farm or their own life and and
just you know no motivation to sell it
or have a company or make a bunch of
money it was really just pure you know
scientific challenge almost but to build
something that works and there's a lot
of cases of that I did want to put that
point I'd like to ask everybody all the
panelists and we do want to go to the
audience too soon but you know in the in
the ultimate basement here what and with
young people in mind what should the
next generation of inventors be
targeting as as sort of doable dreams
Doug Engelbart boy that that beats me
I've been cemented into one set of large
you got something there
I really think there's a sort of a
social reorientation that is be
important to do about the kinds of
issues that really need in important
ways innovation and energy and
commitments and you know money making
isn't the one that's going to resolve
most of those big ones so okay young
kids you know I've said my wise thing
now it's up to you invent a new social
order in other words along those lines
and they say war is too important to
leave to the generals and technology is
too important to leave to the
technologists and more so today then
existed some decades ago technology is
permeates all of our lives and you don't
need to be an engineer or a scientist to
understand technology and its impact or
to have a voice in in its direction I
will give you a practical example in
response to your question a few minutes
ago most a lot of the danger of
technology has to do with when it's
concentrated so technologies like cities
buildings nuclear power plants where you
have a lot of power of one sort or
another concentrated in a small place
can be quite dangerous so in the area of
energy we need to move from these very
centralized you know liquid natural gas
facilities and so forth to decentralized
ones and there are quite a few
innovative projects I've seen involved
in and one of them to create
decentralized energy like microscopic
fuel cells that can be scaled for
America everything from cell phone
battery is up to powering your homes
that are highly decentralized and
general decentralized technology is safe
rooms or communicating over the Internet
is safer than communicating in the city
for example Brian you are the next
generation sure that's the agenda I
think I think you know if I if you would
indulge me I'll paint a little a little
picture of the furniture here I think
there are some important areas that the
next-gen
raishin should target and you know my
specialty happens to be you know
nanotechnology and I think that has a
lot of promise in various fields but if
one could imagine in the future going to
a supermarket and loading up your
shopping cart with all the different
products soup cans and cereal boxes and
you know spatulas if the store is is
stocked that way and being able to
basically walk out of the store you make
no transaction with anybody at any
counter don't stand in any line and you
know basically each of these little
products has a little intelligent tag a
little bit of computer architecture
built into it and allows you to
basically walk through that door and the
door knows what product that you've
actually taken out of the store it the
ducts automatically from your credit
card and you get the statement at the
end of the at the end of the month and
this kind of thing is already happening
in fact when you do this I pass for
gasoline purchases at gas stations and
so on so I think part of the dream is to
have technology embedded everywhere and
making it cheap enough so that you can
afford to put it everywhere I'll give
you one example a car today is
manufactured with as many as twenty
thousand different parts keeping track
of all those different parts actually
adds up to a large portion of the cost
that you pay inventory management
imagine if you had a little computer
computer chip that cost some one
fraction of a penny and embedded in
every bolt and nail and superstructure
and and hood and aluminum alloy wheel
and that way you would be able to keep
track of where all these different parts
are at any point in time and be able to
assemble them right on the spot
so this what do you do in order to
achieve this kind of a dream well you
need some elements of nanotechnology how
do you pattern things at very very very
high volume very cheaply how do you make
disposable cell phones that could be
incorporated into credit cards you
basically buy the credit card it has a
cell phone embedded right in it you
throw it away when you're done this this
is I think some some of the dream that I
see another is is that of you go the
doctor's office and you have basically
your genetic information read out in a
few minutes on a disposable genetic gene
chip then you get into some issues of
well
again technology and then information
there can be a dangerous combination
there but the benefits are that you
would be able to have genetic diseases
read out and diagnosed within a few
minutes on the other hand that
information could be used against you
for insurance policies and so on so
there needs to be a good balance I think
great thank you because I mean these are
the things for years I look at and say
all these things you can picture the
value of innovations in one hand but
they all caused significant changes
throughout society as that adapts to
them and it's that you know different
currents have changed like that that are
going to come into conflict like the
things you mentioned about are also
going to be there so that everybody's
what they what they're where they go and
what they say and what they do
etc can be open you know just easily
tracked so privacy it can you know it's
a very hard chance of surviving can we
adapt our social political structures so
that we can put up and maybe turn that
to an advantage but the current current
society just and have strong rebellion
about that so can we get ready for that
by the time the technology's got it got
ready to use I don't the way we're going
now where we're not getting ready for
things well I think I mean Doug's
question is a tough one to answer it's a
very important one to yours I think the
way I guess I've looked at that is you
know I kind of think of inventions from
the future in two categories one are the
things that you sort of I don't want to
say can predict today but I think sort
of flow out of things that are happening
and we'll certainly keep people busy for
for many many years it's hard to be
specific but if I kind of look at it and
say the medical field you know I think
that we will probably see in the next
3040 years you'll see what we call
personalized medicines ways of
absolutely diagnosing you know the genes
of mapping of each individual and
understanding what that means in terms
of a medical regimen that they should
get we'll see drugs I think that kind of
effects on diseases
you know including cancer that really
don't exist today I think we'll see ways
of as Rob was mentioning of delivering
drugs you know right to whatever target
we want and I think someday we will see
ways of creating new tissues and organs
for treat diseases like diabetes and new
spinal cords for people who paralyzed I
think we'll see those but at the same
time I kind of and there's no particular
direction I'm going when I say this but
I think that some of the greatest
inventions will be things that nobody
here can foresee you know things that
somebody will dream about maybe they'll
answer dose questions or maybe they'll
raise more but those will be inventions
that you know somebody just totally
thinks out of the box I mean if you went
back you know to the turn of the last
century 1900 you know would people ever
dream that we'd have you know airplanes
you know televisions mini computers all
the kinds of things that we see I mean
and I think that the same thing will
continue to happen we just don't know
where where those will come from you
want to make a longshot prediction I
thought I think it make many many
unexpected innovation well pick one that
we're looking at just for fun I mean
which is something that I don't think
most people would think about so are
there ways to even have effects on the
weather in other words would there be
it's not well but maybe in a positive
way
right there are things like hurricanes
that can cause enormous damage and can
kill a lot of people you know
earthquakes that can kill a lot of
people if you could predict those in
ways or if you could you know interfere
with those not necessarily to change it
but if you could if you could you know
save you know many many lives I mean
which would you want to do that ok so
yeah that's all thanks Robert
I was just a Polly ocula and I hope that
lets do to blow so I hope you hurry up
we're working at come from like the
computer the personal computer rounds so
I think in terms of that as far as
future needs for invention directions
and yeah there was a time where we came
out with the first personal computers
and we built the programming language in
somebody could pull it out of the box
and learn a few simple steps and solve
any problem they had where the user was
totally the master the Machine let them
take themselves and gave them more
abilities to go further in the world and
then we started work
on the computers the Lisa and then the
Macintosh kind of followed on from that
but it was a Lisa we had some very
bright bright intellectuals at Apple
that thought how do you make a machine
that works the way a human wants to and
one thing we did was we had just the
blank room and a blank machine no
instructions go in and see what you can
do to it we would tell novitiates people
that weren't computer experts and it had
a mouse and it had different structures
and we've watched them and learn whether
one menu works better than multiple
menus how the window should be shaped
what side of the screen works out better
for people what words and menus are most
suggestive so they find the solutions
with no instruction and we had this
little window where the computer was
just you know like working with the
person like a person and then that
window kind of went away and now we wind
up with complicated programs it's hard
to figure out where they are and you
have to memorize a series of menu
commands rather than just thinking the
way a human would think which is usually
Sarah Dennis
Tuesday 2:00 p.m. write it down little
products that do that sort of thing they
kind of come and they go and they get
lost and the technologies don't come
back and we wind up with what we have
today is error messages that you can't
understand and other dialogues you can't
understand and the check boxes are work
like Brady a buttons and radio buttons
work like checkboxes like nobody cares
about consistency and you check a box
and some words change somewhere to
change a meaning and you never knew it
would have happened and and you can see
where you are but not where you came
from and it's like we have this pretty
much a mess and I keep thinking in terms
of humanization it's always been
important to me and a lot of what Ray
did in his past you know I think I just
try to solve some real human beand
problems like even a piano sounding
right you know or what do you need for a
blind person to read a normal book and
what technologies you have to invent to
do it and it's like humans versus
technology and the humans should be more
important and it's like I feel like
we're kind of losing out and we're not
in as good of places will be someday so
I think that now that we're getting kind
of close to where people have the amount
of computer in their homes and
businesses that they need and we don't
really need a lot of new computers and
new devices don't seem to be coming out
maybe after a period of stability we'll
go back and reevaluate the human
interface again and start going back and
looking searching for these things where
the computer is
like a human and works with us that way
artificial intelligence I hope be you
know a little bit of the key to that
so thanks great I'll mention a couple of
things I I see happening starting with
this decade one important phenomena is
virtual reality now we we can have
virtual meetings today on the Internet
but they don't have the immediacy that
we have here we can't look at each
other's faces we don't have the ability
to express ourselves video conferencing
does a little bit of this but isn't you
actually can't establish eye contact
Indian conferencing and it doesn't have
the resolution but by the end of this
decade we will be able to meet very much
like this with this sense of presence
with with eye contact with
three-dimensional full-immersion visual
auditory virtual reality with images
written on a retina directly from our
eyeglasses and lenses these are
technologies you can see today on this
campus and other other campuses in
prototype form they're not quite high
enough resolution and not ready for
primetime but by the end of this decade
that will be a common way that we meet
the telephone is auditory virtual
reality we'll be adding the visual sense
by the end of this decade interfaces
will we'll have a lot more facility with
human language which is how we like to
communicate and we'd like to be able to
just say what's on our mind and there
are systems emerging they're not quite
good enough yet but with it but they are
within some domains beginning to were
considered by the end of this decade
systems will be able to understand what
you want at least within limited domains
they won't be passing the Turing test so
we won't mistake them for human
intelligence but they will understand
what we want for an e-commerce
transactions scheduling an appointment
or reservation finding information if we
go out past the end of this decade to 20
30 years from now the virtual reality
systems will go inside our brains using
nanotechnology all of this has already
been demonstrated in prototype form the
ability for electronics to interact
actually non-invasively with our
biological neurons and will ultimately
be able to have full immersion virtual
reality incorporating all the senses
people can then beam their whole
of sensory experiences on the internet
and you can plug in experience what it's
like to be someone else all of the plot
concept of Being John Malkovich which
most experiences I think are pretty
boring but well the closest thing the
closest thing to that happening that I
know if is I've got this new arcade
machine called police 9-1-1 and you sit
there and somehow it senses where your
body is you stand on this pad and as you
move around the screen moves and you can
duck behind cop car doors and things
like that so what's coming I like to
this is when you go to call simply say
1-800 and but also I was just thinking
of the late great michael dertouzos of
the computer lab at MIT in an office not
far from here I mean he thought a lot
about making computers and making
technology more humane and more human
centered and he in his office he could
he could give a kind of spoken
instruction to his curtains and they
would open her clothes and he could he
could ask his telephone what the traffic
was like in Phoenix right now or the
weather and in you know Bhutan or
someplace but he thought a lot about
making technology serve human beings
rather than as Steve is saying you know
put us all on these long lists of
indecipherable instructions I'd love to
know what the inventors but also what
all of us think are they kind of human
and what does that actually mean
nowadays to make our technology more
humane other inventors who want to sort
of speak to that or some because I've
been very very concerned and interested
in I'm I'm not trying to stop the
innovations of technology but two things
one is the implications and the rest of
our society for every one of these
families of things that's brought out
and installed they're going to make lots
and lots of changes are we up you know I
come around over and over again then to
its collective smarts that that's one
thing the technology can provide a lot
of improvement but we don't get it by
just plugging in smart machines we're
going to get it by adapting and changing
a lot about the way we think and
collaborate and work together
and that to me that's something
extremely important to get going on to
try to cope and there are lots of
opportunities but I guess I do think you
know some of the things you can do in
medicine lots of people are doing you
know some where again mentioned in the
introduction by rob you know really I
mean they they provide I think great
things in terms of you see sometimes
little children who would die before and
now I think we're able to hopefully
create things that will make people live
longer and you know better lives so I
think there's a lot of things that are
going on that I think hopefully help I
will say general there needs to be much
more public education about science and
technology and its impact so that we can
make intelligent decisions technologies
can have enormous an impact on our lives
the next big revolution is in
biotechnology with our harnessing
information about the genome and
proteomics and so on we're going to be
able to stand human lifespan which has
been the growing extend human aging
overcome any diseases but there's also
tremendous potential for for danger
particularly in the of this kind of
knowledge in the wrong hands and the
things we can do about that I don't
think we're defenseless I think we have
to put resources into technological
immune systems and safeguards and it
requires really the public to guide
these efforts here we are please
you want to tell us who you are you
don't have to hear
here is is really classic technologists
ventures of Technology talking about how
to solve problems or problems that
humans have
but with my hats off to all of you and I
use McIntosh I think the things the
kinds of interventions that are really
most important are the kind to be better
mothers social inventions technical
inventions we have ties up we understand
how to mark tensions
what we need now are social
interventions and we have got flu that's
been brining wilderness now for twenty
thirty years about this and immediately
start thinking well how can we use
computer to do that or how can we build
video conferencing where we've spent
other that social construction together
that says here we have things we need to
do collectively how do we enhance the
collective intellectual
[Music]
technology great dress isn't involving
changing personalities of people to deal
with each other differently and
personalities are pretty you know pretty
stable and transient from a certain age
on so we've got to be talking properly
about how we raise children or something
or maybe school environments I think
there is an interaction between
technology and the kind of human values
and social structures that you're
talking about and I think you have to be
mindful of them and we have to talk
about improving political systems and
social systems in in the context of the
acceleration of Technology I had to get
the acceleration in there if you take an
example I think the Internet is a very
profound an electronic decentralized
electronic communication in general is a
very profound has a very profound
influence on the world both pods have a
negative with the positive it's worth
noting in that it is a very
democratizing force because it keeps
everybody informed I mean when during
that 1991 coup against Gorbachev it
really wasn't Yeltsin standing bravely
on the tank that overturned the coup it
was the clandestine decentralized
electronic communications so that the
totalitarian government couldn't just
see is the TV and radio station and keep
everyone in the dark
everybody was communicating through
early forms of email on teletype
machines faxes and other other forms of
decentralized electronic communication
in the internet now is a very it's
creating a global culture that is much
more important than national boundaries
and products information bounces around
the internet instantly my kids have
friends around the world and create
these communities
it is a very I think it's behind the
trend towards democracy we saw in the
1990s there are a lot of negative
aspects to it also spreads hatred can
provide means for people to communicate
in the clandestine ways to plan
malicious projects and so I mean that
there are there are privacy issues
particularly as this technology becomes
more pervasive it seems to me you're
asking a somewhat different question
which is what is what is the moral
equivalent in the social realm of
inventors in the technological realm and
they're not the same thing I mean maybe
what you're looking for is maybe the
inventor you're looking for as a
politician or psychologist revolutionist
or
is that we understand how to build and
market things we don't understand a
whole lot about building whatever else
it is we need like
but Marie is saying there is a cousin
there is a connection to democracy it's
very hard to explain and I like to hear
I think I was gonna agree that you know
I think inventors have a particular role
to play and in many ways you know
scientists and engineers have particular
roles to play and I think the questions
that you're addressing and the
challenges that you've posed are such
global nature and in fact our you know
require the the you know a battalion of
thousands if not millions to make it
happen you know whole changes in
psychology I think you know as Ray's
mentioned you know the the broadband
internet and so on will allow us to
understand what people are thinking and
talk with them on maybe on nearly a
daily basis a world away that's that's
tremendous but I think I think inventors
have a particular role and our role is
to look at the world and to say you know
to wake up in the morning and say you
know that's a really interesting
reflection in the pool of water that's
sitting outside my window is there any
way that I can use that for
telecommunications okay I mean it's an
odd a combination of things but perhaps
you know the invention of fiber-optic
cable comes from from viewing this
problem so I think inventors maybe are a
little more specific and centralized in
their thinking I mean my thinking is
when when I take a shower and I'm
staying at a four heartless force a
four-star hotel thank you very much
levels in program in Boston you know I
expect all of the all the fine amenities
and that's really wonderful of course I
you know lived in a pretty crappy dorm
here at MIT when I went to school so
this is this is tremendous but you know
I wake up in the morning and I try to
shave and you know what the mirror is
all fogged up and what's my inventive
solution well I take a piece of Kleenex
and clean all
wipe off all of the the condensation why
isn't there a defroster I mean they've
got a heated towel rack okay why isn't
there a defroster on my mirror so you
know I don't I would I would love to
address the big global problems but I
think bit by bit if each inventor does
his work and for that matter you know
each scientist and engineer does their
work for an inventor to feed off of
realistically we're adding little pieces
to the technological puzzle and I think
those get put together with you know
somebody with politics and companies and
money and finances and and then we build
a consensus about what we want to do
about the big global questions well just
a quick comment cuz we did talk about
this at lunch we had lunch together and
we I mean there's a difference between
innovation and invention I mean
invention harnesses innovation in the
area of technology but this but
innovation is something that pervades
fields other than invention the arts
politics psychology teaching can all be
innovative and would I think your point
is we need innovation in other other
fields and the political and social
fields we need more insight into human
psychology and my point earlier was that
this is even more important because of
the profound and rapidly escalating
impact that technology is having on on
human issues well I just point out that
that's the motivating thing starting me
out 50 years ago with the complexity and
urgency is going to grow and we only can
deal with it collectively so there are
things of changes in the way we think
can work and collaborate and the
computers and the communication can make
big differences in that and that's you
know constructive innovation is a lot of
hands out here be as incisive and quick
as you can please
[Music]
name a company and a kind of product in
which there ought to be somebody to deal
with the end product of the invention
every invention coming sort of a clean
up I think that's a good thought we have
a little bit of that in terms of
liability people certain types of damage
they can be sued and there are
regulations and in areas of impact on
the environment but I think that's the
direction we need to move into because
technology does have a very pervasive
effect and I proposed it's that we
actually create specific programs to in
a sense clean up some of the dangers
that are created by new technologies you
know we've suddenly woken up have a list
of a hundred different vulnerabilities
we have just with conventional
technology and the new ones that
emerging are also a double-edged sword
so we need to we need to deal with it
the car puts out pollution to the extent
that we don't want pollution well
somebody has to pay for it but it's
really the person buying the car it has
an extra cost it has the cost of the car
and the cost of the cleanup and the
price tag should be put on the car but
if any one company tries to do that
every other company's gonna sell cheaper
cars so obviously the solution is
somewhere above a company above an
inventor
it's like political or something please
hi this is on another question that was
asked earlier about the qualities to
create an inventor what about the
question of chaos I have found that
inventors are willing to go into that
realm of chaos they also think that the
end result that we're talking about is
also filled with a chaos that
reverberates out you know into the when
you have a new invention you say
something about chaos sort of Pandora's
box I mean yeah I think I think what
inventors try to do is perhaps bring
order to chaos an inventor might go into
a conference on materials research or on
nanotechnology or this or that and I
think you know we'll be able to take
various ideas that might not necessarily
initially seem connected and put them
together into a new way and bring order
to this kind of chaos of ideas I think
that's what you do anytime that you sit
down with a bunch of people and
basically brainstorm you're bringing in
all these ideas from all these different
directions creating something concrete
and then you got to bring it to the next
step and that's to ask the question okay
this is interesting what are we going to
do with it I think that the brightest
most admirable inventors are the ones
that invent things in a way that reduces
the chaos instead of increasing it but
gives you just as much capability
another comment on casma my own
technical field is something called
pattern recognition which is really the
study of chaos and finding patterns in
very chaotic information like looking at
in a scene and seeing seeing this very
chaotic swirl of visual information but
being able to make some sense out of it
and that's actually the heart of human
intelligence and probably the most
profound new technological capability
that will emerge in this century is
machines with increasing amounts of of
human-like intelligence which is based
on this ability to find patterns in
chaos please depart
helping people deal with increasing
complexity and at the time that he was
beginning his work it seems like that
was a much less obvious problem than it
is now so I was wondering if there was
anything specific that led him to take
his research in that direction can you
rephrase that what what was it about
complexity that got you home fifty years
ago why complexity if I tell you it'll
reveal this very country boy naive yet
that I started a couple of months before
that I happened to get engaged at the
weekend and driving to work on Monday I
thought well I'm going to get married
and have kids and live happily ever
after and that's all very great and
suddenly I started aligning myself to
thinking about the work and for some
strange reason all I saw was a empty
hallway nicely lit going on down forever
and I just realized with a real shock I
didn't have any real professional goals
and before the day was out I tried
different goals and I latched on to one
that I'm embarrassed to tell you about
it's like saying oh why didn't I invest
my career to maximize the return in
benefits to mankind honest
that's alright but I spent the next few
months trying to figure out what kind of
a crusade to go on and that's that's
when I began to realize how complex the
world is and you hear stories about
saying oh boy
here these natives are living in a way
where the swamps get so much mosquitoes
and malaria is crippling them and
everything else will go in and will
clear the swamps well great then 30
years later they've over populated the
area and they've ruined the environment
and they're worse off see so you say
okay how do I design a crusade whose
results have a chance of really helping
rather than the secondary effects of it
being worse or something and it's very
complex organizing a crusade anyway
you-you-you say well I need a business
manager I go down the streets looking
for business managers of Crusades and
they don't seem so one Saturday I just
thought oh you know it's just really
very very complex and somehow that all
came to get it pretty soon as yes
complex the problems are getting more
and more complex and urgent that have to
be dealt with collectively and our
ability to deal collectively with
complex urgent problems isn't improving
as fast as a complexity and urgency are
so where is that going to leave us so
the naive country boy says Oh that'll be
what I'll commit a career to and one
thing led to another so I get all this
images about how we actually can change
our way of thinking and interacting and
vocabulary is going to change and the
very symbols were used to portray those
concepts are going to start evolving and
changing because we can portray them in
such different ways dynamically etc and
the old-fashioned way of that that's
that's the way you should get your
knowledge is looking at a page and
that's still out there and I says hey
boy that's the result of a very old
technology to have symbols put on there
like that so how can I put them on
dynamically in color and shift to view
so how I want them so I just feel like
there's a great deal to learn about how
we can deal with all of that
and improve our ability collectively to
develop knowledge in ways in which we
can really very rapidly put it together
and we don't have to wait till you
publish the next textbook etc anyway
I mean that's been a debate recently one
forum was kicked off by cover story that
bill joy wrote in Wired magazine that
some of you may have seen and he and I
have been pair to serve optimist and
pessimist around that issue which is
probably an oversimplification but I
think my point is not that we're
embarked on a project specifically to
create artificial intelligence but it's
inevitable result of lots of little
steps each of which is quite
conservative and makes sense by itself a
little bit faster computer software
that's more responsive than the kind of
frustrating software that that Steve was
describing but the inevitable result of
hundreds of these steps is artificial
intelligence we're not specifically
sitting down and creating nanotechnology
nanotechnology is the inevitable end
result of hundreds of projects which
make things a little smaller with
Shrinking technology at an exponential
rate and the inevitable result of that
is that 10 20 years from now most
technology will be have its key features
measured in nanometers and the
inevitable end result of faster
computers and more sophisticated
software and software that understands
language better motivated by wanting to
have better user interfaces all of which
are economic imperatives I mean if a
company says well you know an AI might
be dangerous therefore when I'm not
gonna create more intelligent software
we'll be out of business because there's
an economic imperative to it and I
pointed out that out to Bill joy I mean
son is continued to create more
intelligent software and faster
computers and more powerful networks
because it's an economic imperative
[Music]
economic imperative driven by business
which is fine and good like that but it
still is going to create real problems
that today we wouldn't have a
who us how we would cope with that so if
you get more and more things that are
being created that are smarter than
people why why the hell should they pay
much attention to us pretty soon if
they're smart enough they'll get
together and say who needs these
creatures well I think it's a real issue
if you describe today to people 200
years ago
particularly if you emphasize some of
the negatives enough explosive power to
end all mammalian life and all the other
dangers that we live with they would
think it's crazy to to go down that path
but we didn't get here by embarking on a
single project to create the present
world it it's done step at a time and
there are profound benefits I had
something to finish and I think this
there is a moral imperative not just an
economic imperative to continue
technology development because they're
still not millions but billions of
people who are suffering from poverty
and disease and other things other
flexions which technology can and will
overcome so there's there's plenty of
moral reason to continue technology but
the but and technology is a double-edged
sword and the so we we do have to
address this this negative sorry but I
think it's unrealistic to think that
we're not going to continue moving
forward can I just get please that yes
no us no one's saying stop it to do
those cures the thing is people are
saying well I'm not I'm just saying that
if we don't get smarter about the how we
handle it and the things you talk about
about how the technology over the last
two centuries has changed well all that
change has happened at a very slow rate
because technology evolved relatively
very slowly and our society has a sort
of a time constant about how it adjusts
and adapts and everything like that the
great answers that thought I want to
change the subject
[Music]
surpasses human psychologically and
socially to adjust and deal
and question
for example can you take
what are the best examples
[Music]
we're abilities
as forward quickly so have their
department weeks as
and
[Music]
I mean I would give the example of the
Internet as the question was roughly
examples where of speedy and and happy
adaptation of technology to social order
[Music]
I think the Internet is a very profound
development it's it emerges from the
technological world but it's had
profound impact on every other severe
certainly education politics and it's
it's a it's an enormous communication
vehicle and it's not a static thing it's
going to increase in its realism and
it's it's fundamentally a communication
medium where we can communicate with
other people and our ability to do that
over this worldwide network is going to
increase it's creating communities that
are global and it's creating kind of a
global culture at society that has a lot
of impacts that are not specifically
technological and also while it's true
the technology's accelerating a profound
trend as a technology is becoming more
human I mean the first computers were
behind glass walls and then Steve helped
out sherry in the personal computing
revolution where computers none were
sitting on our desks and then ultimately
we were carrying them under our arms
notebooks and now we're putting them in
our pockets and ultimately they're going
to be woven in our in our clothing and
they're going to become more communicate
more in human ways so it doesn't
necessarily require humans to become
more technologically savvy in order to
use technology it's becoming more like
us and becoming more into intertwined
with our lives and allows us to do
things that aren't specifically
technological so when teenage kids are
creating new music and sharing music
using technology that's that's a non
technological impact of sophisticated
technology and we're going to see that
more and more I'd say overall the the
Internet has been a very positive sort
of happily yeah I mean I'm younger than
anybody here in the panel and may have a
little bit of naivete but so I'm kind of
an eternal optimist really about
technology I have a much more rosy view
on what can happen in the future simply
by looking at what has happened in the
past I mean I think anybody here in this
audience would have you know a hard time
arguing against the notion that your
life today is much better than it
then it could have been maybe you know
only seventy or only fifty years ago
again the example that Ray given you
know two hundred years ago you might be
dead already because the life spans were
so short back then I think this is a
trend that's going to continue on into
the future I think you know we brought
up the notion that perhaps the advances
in technology will somehow outstrip our
ability to control it or understand it
or be able to use it in in good and you
know wise ways but I think in the past
we've seen that we've been able to
overcome those problems I mean the
development of the atomic bomb for gosh
sakes you know in the end yes okay we
got close to the edge perhaps one could
say but in the end we've we've you know
we're able to work out those differences
those problems find technological
solutions find political solutions find
sociological solutions for this kind of
this kind of thing so one example cars
today okay it took 20 years to do it a
car today puts out about 1/100 of the
pollution that a car did only 20 years
ago that has had a profound effect on
atmospheres worldwide now of course we
have many more cars that's a big problem
okay but it's better but a two-cycle
lawnmower puts out 200 times as much as
one car this this is true this is true
SST illuminated resource flag capacity
wanna meet by that
in order to amend new things to sell
their product you have to be meeting
some sort of need and for every need
there this asymptotes like an endpoint
that need I think not what I mean is
character disease we care every
possibility they master every biological
process we could live forever if we
create artificial intelligence that
could translate any language for us we
no longer need to learn any language
aside from a basic set of commands
activate this translate course these are
waiting which technology is making us a
and this is really from Western G point
where you know we create more needs
because Islands but I think technologies
that that could be then if that would
increase our cognitive abilities that
would make us more human and we talked
about how to get a better quality our
small way of life are valid is your
question that same order that we're
running out of needs and necessity
how's that making us think whether or
not need human need is a finite resource
and in my view the uniquely human thing
is to seek broader horizons what need
was Beethoven's Ryung to to fulfill and
is that finite I mean ultimately our
human civilizations creating knowledge
and by knowledge I include art and music
and invention and literature and human
discourse and our political systems and
human knowledge you can actually measure
it is growing exponentially and I think
as we overcome some of our afflictions
people can become more creative there's
no limit to the amount of knowledge we
can seek the more we know the more we
know we don't know
he's the profits of inventing a gadget
like that any picture the process of a
new drug for cancer and talisman picture
whether you're coming up with a gimmick
or not
I think I think the truly important and
innovative the one the kinds of
inventions that are really have impact
okay probably it's not going to be the
laser pen or the tickle-me-elmo for the
following for the following reason I
think truly innovative inventions take
advantage of some effect some noticing
of something happening in the
environment around you often times it
comes from the field of physics or that
comes from the field of biology or
neurobiology the noticing how drugs
interact from each other so I think
those are the kinds of inventions that
will have true impact and eventually
wind up being the foundations upon which
we build gimmicks
article The New Yorker careful world
it was a very very different world born
to that change suffered buildings huge
societal
Bob Langer surprised him with an answer
yeah wish I had a good one uh yeah I
kind of thought you know I think I know
what you're saying I mean you're saying
like the that in between 1900 and 1950
there was this you know giant thing and
what's happened the last 50 years but uh
but I I don't know I mean I think a lot
an awful lot has happened the last 50
years - I don't I you know so it's hard
for me to say I mean if I compared the
last 50 years to any other 50 years I
would think it would still be a pretty
giant thing it's just that that
particular 50 years at least as you know
some of those events like you know cars
and planes and all that was you know
it's a pretty big deal III guess I still
think there's gonna be an awful lot
ahead of us as well I mean you know
whether it'll do exactly those 50 years
hard to know and that's kind of a
dramatic thing sometimes you know the
foundations are laid and those
foundations are laid before and then all
of a sudden these kind of spectacular
things that you envision you know jump
out at you but it's not necessarily
because you know there's like they say
this the science or the engineering may
have happened even before that it's just
that that's what we say I don't know if
that makes sense
right you want to give me acid that he
knew you were gonna get yeah I'll give
you the answer you expected but I mean
car first of all cars have emerged
before 1900 as did trains and I'm the
world changed in between 1900 1950 but I
don't know that it was that profound I
think it's changed a lot more between
1915 and now I have studied this issue
for four
for quite some time and have measured
quantitatively certain technological
trends I mean if you look at certain
measurements that you can do
quantitatively like computational power
communication speed our knowledge about
the human brain and the ways of
measuring that our biological knowledge
the size of Technology all of these
different facets are growing it
remarkably smooth with exponential rates
despite the chaos I mean I I have these
various charts where you put these
different projects and measure them in
certain ways and they form these very
smooth exponential curves despite the
fact that each point on those curves is
a function of tremendous chaos and
competition and venture capital and
human drama nonetheless the the powers
of these technologies are growing
exponentially if you look at what you're
alluding to which is sort of the pace of
technical change the rate of paradigm
shift as I call it I've plotted that as
well and that is also growing
exponentially we're roughly doubling the
paradigm shift rate every decade and
that goes back to the dawn of technology
where the first steps took thousands or
tens of thousands of years like stone
tools fire the wheel then a thousand
years ago things like printing and chips
took centuries to take hold and now we
have paradigm shifts like the World Wide
Web that take root in in just a few
years time so we are there is a there is
a an exponential growth to the pace of
of Technology and which means the next
25 years will see a hundred years of
change at today's rate of change which
is why some of the social issues
discussed here are are urgent because
the pace of change is speeding up I
think I think that's clear
commercialization
I want to postulate he said no invention
gross
[Music]
the entrepreneurs can be considered the
heroes of invention to point out maybe
somewhat of a sobering fact for all you
budding inventors out there something
like only one out of 100 patents
actually gets turned into something and
maybe only 1/100 of those actually turns
into something useful maybe one of those
actually kind of useful used something
useful that people want so in many ways
I think you know we talked about cash as
being the the commodity of necessity for
for an inventor to take his idea to the
next step I think a lot of credit does
need to go in fact to to the
entrepreneurs out there that are willing
to risk their own capital their own
reputations and so on to turn a very
very risky idea into something new and
novel and hopefully something that can
change you know society please
I have one wish that inventors would
start instead of going more towards
complexity that they would reverse and
close to simplicity so anybody can hear
somebody mention the car has so many
thousand parts well why is it why
wouldn't meet all those parts if if we
could reverse it and use fewer parts and
show the genius really in the making
things simpler not anybody can put
another button on a car and put ten more
parts and so on so that's my wish
you know I I think I think that can be
addressed at least in some particular
areas today
I'll give you you know one example the
fabrication of a computer chip today is
unbelievably complex a typical plant
like an intel plant to produce a typical
pink pentium might run between one and
two billion dollars for one factory and
that's supposed to be three or four
billion by two years from now and maybe
ten billion by you know six years from
now complexity upon complexity
complexity in order to achieve the end
result so you know one of the things
that i've been working on is is how do
you in fact make a computer chip but do
it in 10 steps fabricate it in 45
minutes so there are people that are
working on the simplification of things
and when it comes to that you know the
manufacturer of a car i think a lot of
those innovations will come from
material science a lot of the reasons
why you need a lot of parts in a car is
that steals and aluminum's aren't nearly
as strong and robust and as rigid as
they would need to be carbon nanotubes
which are new materials development
coming out and being discussed at
various conferences worldwide you know
offer the possibility for the first time
you really could think of building an
elevator between you know the earth and
the moon and it would be you know
structurally have great integrity so and
you know the same kind of technology
could be implemented for the building of
you know maybe even injected molded
airplanes or extruded cars fewer parts
absolutely
speak up Mary Howard comparative Media
Studies is just a point of irony
I've been a fan of dogs for a long time
and I think it's incredibly ironic which
maybe half the audience must realize
maybe not that in fact he was introduced
as the inventor of the mouse in this
context which is maybe one of the most
extreme examples of the context of it's
more that would contextualize it's more
important than mentioning something he's
me
I'd like to retroactively will introduce
him as an inventor of argument nobody's
actually said this but he invented and I
think it was brought up a little bit
earlier without specifically saying it
by somebody who worked in the past but
argument is about the idea of an
invention in fact it's also behind the
invention of the web and usually it's
attributed to Ted Nelson in Vannevar
bush and died but even beyond that his
real point was how can we make a
technological enhancement to human
intelligence to let us cope better with
everything that we've done is that the
invention of the mouse is actually an
ironic introduction I think in the
context of the discussion that we've
seen because he actually is best known
for having in the entire text community
invented a system for handling these
issues of the escalation of knowledge in
the management
in fact using metric knowledge
management in many ways I already noted
thank you do you feel that today's
intellectual property laws or hinder the
development of new inventions in our in
our technological society well I think
it's a it's a very important issue and
you need intellectual property to some
extent to protect the creation so that
you can attract the capital to create
them in the first place on the other
hand there is a real issue in patent law
which has a fixed 20 years I mean it's
it's bounced back in about 15 17 and 20
but it's approximately 20 years of
protection and the significance of 20
years is changing profoundly 20 years 20
years ago was an interesting amount of
time but today you're talking about
being able to protect maybe some basic
concept through many revolutions of
technology as we go forward the
significance of 20 years is going to
become greater and greater so I do think
we need to to revisit that and there's
because of the complexity of technology
a lot of patents get issued that aren't
really don't deserve patent protection
because someone has done something on a
computer and then they say well I'm
doing the same thing but on the web and
then they create a patent and you
probably couldn't contest that but
because of the vagaries of jury trials
where juries don't really understand the
technology the patent has power anyway
so I think there I think we need to
revisit that some of the aspects of
patent protection we mix 20 years
despite the fact that the significance
of time is changing you specifically do
patenting in the medical world is too
much stuff patentable well I think you
know I think that that also is an
evolving thing I think
that I I think by and large what happens
is pretty good in other words I think
it's a somewhat self-correcting system
but it takes time to correct itself so
what happens is you know there may be
things that you know and this is
certainly cannot come up with the genome
that gets patented or allows to get
patented that maybe shouldn't but I
think people start to realize what might
have been obvious you know in other
words what was obvious today is
different you know ten years ago and it
will be different ten years from now so
it's a question of people catching up
with that system and so I think in most
cases things are pretty good in medicine
but I think that there's got to be a
continuing reexamination education for
you know examiner's and so forth to
really figure out what's obvious and and
to really interpret that an intelligent
way but I still feel overall it's
reasonable can we take one more question
and then quit while we're still hungry
please
we'll let you answer those other over
here suggested that the mouse is an
augmenting invention others may or may
not be and I wonder if we're still as
inventors have the ultimate goal of
humanity or adulterate goal of humanity
in mind or are we just looking more
short-term each time we do it is
basically the lifecycle of these
inventions changes and what not are we
just looking at how to make better
Sall here or a better drug here as
opposed to thinking more along lines of
well what drugs in the world are needed
to make many better well the ultimate
goal humanity must be to smile more and
frown less so we kind of aren't touching
that I'm not sure I would agree with
that I'm quite happy frowning sometimes
and they're probably some drugs we could
take where we'd smile all the time and
I'm not sure that's the goal the thing
the one thing that's I think the key
thing that separates Homo sapiens from
other species is our accumulating
knowledge base other species
communicates they do use tools but none
of that evolves and they don't have a
growing species wide shared knowledge
base that evolves over time and reflects
a dialogue among all the members of that
species we're the only species that does
that and that knowledge includes such
grand things as music and art and as
well as all the other kinds of
conversations that we have and my mind
that is the goal of humanities is to is
to continue that species Y dialogue and
create more profound knowledge well yeah
just to deal with the medicine
specifically but I think you know in a
larger sense what I what I'll say I
think it's true for most people here I'm
not necessarily speaking for myself but
more as an MIT professor who sees
students
come in and what drives in and I think
what drives them isn't to make one new
thing or you know I think it is to you
know make the world a better place to
make people healthier let's say if
that's the area they choose to study it
may come out that maybe they do one
thing but I think the broad driving
forces that I see so many students
postdocs and scientists come in as they
and I think that's what drives most
inventors is that they want to see
something good happen and I think they
do have you know the long-term benefit
in mind that may not be true for
everybody but I think it's probably true
for most people right good you know my
dream I think is actually coming true to
a large extent thanks to the internet
and broadband people are talking and I
think that's that's the foundation of
how to solve a lot of these global
worldwide problems people are talking
and what language are they speaking well
it is true that you can communicate
across you know sociological and
political and maybe even biological
boundaries with for example music but
there is another common language and I
think there is one of that of invention
you know you show some person invention
one and then maybe a superior invention
number two there may be some consensus
that number two is actually better than
number one and maybe we can create one
that's a number three that's even better
than number two so I think there is a
common dialogue in the in the you know
the languages invention the language is
in engineering
the language is science good you get the
last word Wow I had one wife and three
daughters and I was not used to having
the last word
[Applause]
well I think while you're talking about
about accumulating knowledge etc is is
very much akin to what I feel is an
important aspect it needs a lot more
attention specifically for how we do
develop our common knowledge and they're
rated you know if the world knowledge
doubles every six months what are our
schools going to do and everybody that's
out working in a job how are they going
to get retreaded so you know the they're
just huge changes that we they're coming
about and we're not lining up is that
the mission is to keep the conversation
going with accumulating information all
the time but then also to know when to
stop I have to leave thank you very very
much for your attention it's been an
honor to be among you
you